bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
welcome to the Deen show peace be unto
you I'm Eddie your host and today we
have on the show to share his story with
us is the bodyguard former bodyguard for
the world renowned famous heavyweight
champion of the world now you gotta know
this man Muhammad Ali
that's right Muhammad Ali his former
bodyguard is gonna be talking to us you
need Lane shake need Lane Muhammad he's
gonna be on in a few so you don't want
to go nowhere because it's gonna be an
exciting show when we come back here on
the dean she'll be right back
there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger why did that maybe it maybe is
just to break the ice
welcome back to the Dean show I'm your
host and just in a couple minutes we're
gonna be bringing out the former
bodyguard and he Lane Muhammad was also
a black belt in many different martial
arts he also started training the most
effective martial art not just because I
trained at Gracie Jiu Jitsu Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu but because the Gracie family
indeed proved that it was so he's
somebody that I got a chance to sit with
very remarkable man before we bring him
out we're just gonna bring you up to
speed on some current news some things
that are going on in the community we
want to talk to you about our brother no
man
Ali you can we want to send a shout out
to him he just had a baby boy may Allah
bless you and your family we also have
chat snapchat Islam with the shakes that
everyone needs to know Sayed ugly Sheikh
Mohammed Sheikh ugly and son I'm
anna-marie I got a chance to be with
down in India at the peace conference
such a wonderful man
and I'd like to also thank all the other
sheiks that I had a chance to meet with
down India at the peace Convention and
doing some big things over there
incredible peace the solution to
humanity tune in to peace TV wonderful
Channel now they can be watched at chat
is Nam Kham check that out we want to
increase your knowledge look into the
programs that they have on the weekends
Friday and Saturdays now before we bring
out in the lane Mohamed former bodyguard
for Muhammad Ali a couple more things
want to bring you up to speed with
Islamic online university dr. bilal
philips
check it out is free increase your
knowledge and earn all these wonderful
rewards another thing that you want to
really check up into we also have a
wonderful brother and many of you who
are out there thank you for supporting
the Dean show this brother actually
started a dower drive DVD drive you know
we started the DVDs for dower
we've gotten a lot of these wonderful
shakes a lot of these do a lot of these
people who are out there trying to help
people understand the most misunderstood
way of life and we've gotten to speak
with them sharing their stories sharing
their experiences sharing their
knowledge putting it on where you can
actually watch all of it for free at the
Dean show calm but some people want to
have the means to be able to give it to
people so we've put it down made the
shows into a volume one with two discs
that you can go ahead and share it with
the world
we've done a lot of the hard work now
all you got to do is contribute by one
buy in bulk that's what we're trying to
really get you to do for the different
Dawa organizations get these DVDs and
get them out to the world get them out
so everybody can share in this wonderful
reward and get to know more about this
way of life of peace peace through
submitting yourself to the one who is
the owner of peace the creator of the
heavens in there that's right so check
out half date the drive is going on at
half date.com and the brother by the way
is a beautiful brother who started also
half Dean calm he's trying to get
married so we encourage all the sisters
to get your guardian
check out half Dean calm and see if we
can get those single people to get
together not to go on dates not to go
out and do things that they shouldn't be
doing but doing it the right way doing
it how the crater of the heavens and
earth wants you to do it that's right
through marriage so check out this
brother Muhammad's website have
date that's what you can learn more
about the dower Drive contribute get
involved so we can get the Dean show out
so we can get this message of peace out
to the world and at the same time check
out half a Dean and you can check out
this brother he put his portfolio there
and hopefully insha'Allah God willing
and get this brother married I think
they're signaling we got our brother
former bodyguard for Muhammad Ali that's
right Muhammad Ali his former bodyguard
shake me lain shaken Elaine can you hear
me brother yes I can hear you good thank
God thank you for being with us on the
Deen show thank you very much yeah I'm
glad to be here this is my first time so
as we hear it you used to be the
bodyguard for the former champion of the
world heavyweight champion and the
world-famous Muhammad Ali yes sir for
those people who might have been locked
up in a room for a long time they
haven't been out and they don't know who
Muhammad Ali is tell us a little bit
about it please well Muhammad Ali was a
former heavyweight world champion in the
United States oh well all over the world
and what he done in the boxing world is
unmatched and what he also done outside
the boxing world is unmatched
so most people he was one of the most
recognized faces on the planet and I
haven't had this gracious opportunity to
work with him as a bodyguard someone
might think why would a champion
heavyweight champion like him need a
bodyguard
well the same things that he can't do
for himself you know you don't have eyes
on the side of him and behind him so you
need someone to keep certain people's
away from him that are approaching him
and to have a critical eye and watching
and protecting him because he was a very
public figure and even though Muhammad
Ali was a person that is a person that
everybody seems to love but you do have
people who maybe have some mental
sickness illness and that might approach
them in a way that's inappropriate so
the job of the person they're secure
a figure like that is to make sure that
this don't happen now you're also a
top-ranking martial arts black belt is
that correct yes I've been doing martial
art for a period over 35 years when I
teach Azabu moontak at door of the swarm
Academy of martial arts that's in
Jamaica Queens as well as in Atlanta
Georgia if you go to the websites Wawa
shot calm you'll see what we teach is
called Kaoru Kaoru boxing judo rules
jiu-jitsu so as a young man tell us did
you grow up in a Christian household yes
I grew up in Iran what you require was
the infrastructure was based on
Christianity my father mother I first
started out as a Catholic and then from
there I moved on to to back to become
Anabaptists is it true that your father
was a deacon yeah my father was a big
deacon later on he got more emerged in
the church I'm from a New Yorker isn't
it but years ago my father moved to
Atlanta bought property and helped build
our church with over 1500 members and
his name is engraved in church because
he died about six years ago and his name
is engraved on the church and he was a
head deacon of that church he helped
build it and financing and everything
kneel ain't Ella did you grow up
believing that Jesus was God and your
Savior yes this is where I was taught
that he was God and he was am i same my
personal Savior and I had to separate
him I was baptized you know dipped in
water and you know and told that I had
accepted Jesus as my Lord and Savior so
tell us hey Leanne how did this change
in your life happen well that came about
I was a very troubled youth when I grew
up at the late age of 12 years old I get
in trouble and I was sent to you fall
and from there I just continued aspiring
out of control because I really not I
really didn't have no rules and guidance
in my household my father mother they
went to church you know
in a while but really rules from the
scripture was not really applied in the
house and I really didn't have no
guidance so the street gave me guidance
and I joined gangs and you know cliques
and stuff like that and I sort of
spiraled out of control and so by the
age of 16 or 17 I was really on a
mission of self-destruction and at the
age of 15 my father put me out of the
house tell us a little bit about this
baptism well they take you in the day
that I was supposed to subdue sirs of my
Lord and Savior they have a either
man-made pool some water some place and
behind a curtain and next thing I know I
was scared to death and a native
Reverend he's in the pool and he and
they say a few things and they take you
under the water in the name of the
Father and name of the son a name of the
Holy Ghost and I set the dish without
real any knowledge I really did I really
didn't understand what I was doing tell
us what is the belief now your belief
now about the one who is so beloved and
dear to our hearts Jesus Christ peace be
upon him well
hundred in now by the guidance of Allah
and you know there was another track of
me before I became to this the Quran and
Sunnah and I guess you are actually
about that that just speed it up I came
to understand that Jesus and Islam we
called him ISA and Lee Selim may peace
be upon him that he was a prophet of God
a major one of the major prophets of God
and no prophet of God has ever de
claimed to be divine they came with the
divine message that God came but there
was not divine there was human beings
and that God had raised up spiritually
and they came with a message and he saw
they seldom came with the messages of
truth how do you tackle the argument
that some people adamantly make about
Jesus being God well I saw something
quickly my father before he died
I went to visit him in George Georgia in
the 80s and when I was married at that
time I had small children and one of my
brothers her name is Yasmine and I hope
she's watching this she's an adult now
of course she was in a room planner for
a cousin who was about 10 of her cousins
they was playing in the living room and
they had an argument there was talking
about Jesus and how Christian cousins
were saying Jesus was God and he has me
and said no Allah is God he's the only
God so my ex-wife she was at the table
with me and she was pinching me because
she was worried that my daughter was
gonna really bring this into the kitchen
where we was having dinner the dining
room and we was eating with my father
mother brothers and sisters all at the
table who are Christians and sure that
she did and she came directly to the
table she said daddy they're saying that
Jesus God who is God is Jesus God I told
them that a large God and my wife was
very scared and I was turned to have my
bed everything was quiet and I said
that's right Allah is God and my father
became very angry he was disappointed
that I was teaching my children this
type of concept so what happened the
next morning my father had to go to the
church to teach Sunday School it was on
a Saturday and my mother and father was
getting red dress but it wasn't inviting
me to come to the church number one
because our world was like a Khamis
clothing that was something like I have
on Anna and I had a one of these goofy
hats on so he was uncomfortable so the
rest out and left me but the church was
about half a block away from the house
so I decided to get dressed and go to
the church and when I opened the door of
the church
I guess this record there was out all
eyes is on me all eyes was on me because
he had opened the door and they see this
person with this goofy hat on he's funny
looking close to them strange clothes
and they looked and I was invited in and
one of the ladies who was teaching the
Sunday school service she invited me to
sit with her a large group and my father
was teaching the other group and he
to sweat profusely so they was talking
about Musa Moses on a seller may peace
be upon him and the things that he went
through and everything so what happened
speed this up they asked me to make some
comments and I've made some comments
just general knowledge that a Muslim has
about these prophets because we loved
them and they're the same prophets in
Islam is and Christine is same practice
in Islam because it's one link and
they're all brothers the prophets of
brothers to one another so the Reverend
our pastor must have has some type of
device that he could heal what was going
on in this big church and he stepped out
from there back and he's signaled to me
to come to him and did he invite him in
the back room and the pastor was I guess
about 60 or 70 years old then I was in
my 20s and he asked me so you are not a
Christian I said no I'm not a Christian
he said he said you amuse them I said
yes I'm a Muslim
and he asked me questions about the
scripture and he was very impressed at
the answers that gave you where did you
learn this as I learned this from the
Quran the book of Allah from their
Messenger of Allah and they were Selim
and he was so convinced that what I was
saying was truthful that he invited me
to give the talk for the day so when I
came back out east I play in the organ
as a signal to the pastor to come out
and start the sermon give us a
demonstration of how this sounds like
well okay his take me near the cross
that's an old traditional song among
Baptists people so when he heard that I
was a signal to come out the organ was
playing the people was saying that so he
came out so praise the Lord he waved his
hand everybody get quiet and he said we
have a special guest with us today
my father is sweating profusely now he's
really concerned and my mother and
father I mean my mother and brother
sister was sitting on the front row and
their mouth was open like this and
disbelief and as they were disbelieving
me the night before Dave's time I was
all wrong here their pastor saw
something and what I was saying was
truthful so what he said he said we have
a special guest and he called his name
Neelam which is pronounced
Lane vomit now as he said but his
brother he's he's deacon now son and
they're all eyes were on the deacon
because his son is a Muslim he said he's
not a Christian he's a Muslim he said
but I find what he said was very
truthful and I want him to give the talk
for the day so I ended up giving a talk
and I was talking about moosa
aleihsalaam moses how the people gave
him trouble as he was trying to give
them the truth out a reject and they
kept rebelling are we gonna do that the
same today so it went over very well and
then when I went back home the pastor
had called me in the back to me with
some other reverence so my father mother
went home to help me about another hour
when I got home opened the door
all my family was standing up on their
feet and clapping like this and my
mother come and hugged me my stepmother
actually she came and hugged me and said
god bless you I didn't know you was a
man of the cloth and my father he
doesn't bowed his head and just shook my
hand you know he's a good job son and
basically I was it and before he died
I've done my best to explain to towhee
the oneness of Allah he accepted that
there's only one God but when I said
Muhammad someone I was selling he
rejected it so I made effort and my
mother's nearing her 80s and I need to
visit her my stepmother and see if I can
reach her but I did the best I could at
that time so that's what happened so now
someone asks you who's paying the price
for your sins now what do you say yeah
the concept of dying from the sin and
the reason of sin this is not a concept
in Islam as we know Adam Elise Elam is
the father of all men and how Eve is the
mother of all men and women and when
they made a mistake in paradise and
Allah in the Quran says Columbia have
any Adam we have honoured the children
of adam and Allah and they made tobin
and gave an Allah forgave them so in
Islam whatever you do is upon you you
come in this world as a blank page and
all whatever you do whether
good or bad it's from you we don't have
to worry about it being passed down to
us so there's no original sin so I don't
I do not have this view answer what a
Christian comes to me I said that Jesus
died for your sins
excited cetera I informed them of the
Islamic point of view tell us your
experience with the nation well I was in
the Nation of Islam and I came about
that as I said i was a tough very
trouble you and I came into the Nation
of Islam at a very young age I was
actually influenced by at the age of
fourteen years old and what happened
they used to be at the subway stations
in New York there it was all over but it
was like ants everywhere in New York and
in a predominately ghetto areas there
was there and this is unfortunate that
the people of Quran and Sunnah there was
not available so this was what was in my
environment so I thought this was Islam
and so one day I was going to the subway
and every morning this person was
stopped me and he said get your Mohammed
speaks your Mohammed speaks get your
Mohammed speaks and I would try to avoid
him and I ended up buying a paper and it
had a picture of this man big fat
african-american black man eating that
would appear to be a rat there's a
cartoon with a rat going in his mouth
and he was sweating profusely and it
says cat rat dog this is what a pig is
made of this is the concept for the
nation Islam so I went home and that
weekend
there's edition in an african-american
culture that we meet on Sunday morning
have breakfast so we have a breakfast
and that beverage consists of fatback
meat I don't know if they still anybody
know what that is anymore but I remember
it and bacon eggs and you know a lot of
pork and I used to love eating pork a
stuff from a la zine but I used to love
Eden so what happened I wouldn't eat any
of it so my father looked at me and my
brother sister said what's wrong with
you how come you know II didn't know
meat how come you know you net I said I
don't need any more pork I did my father
looked over and he said why you're not
eating pork and I said I said because it
has 999 diseases could this with the
Nation of Islam it was the brother told
me at the subway station and it says
made of a cat rat Nadal
and when I said hey where'd you get
everything from I said I've from the
Nation of Islam and he cursed Eliezer
Muhammad out at the table and he took
all the pork and poured it on my plate
to make me eat it
and he didn't know about five or six
years later that I from this day form of
my knowledge I haven't eaten any of that
sense and I joined that that's when I
came about joining the Nation of Islam
now how did you make the transition from
the nation which is more of a
nationalistic movement to Islam which
brings all people from all nationalities
white yellow black pink purple doesn't
matter what color you are real Islam
brings people together as true brothers
and sisters of humanity tell us how did
you make this transition to the real
e-stat well I get from the Nation of
Islam I joined in eastern Islam as I
told I was a trouble you for night I was
incarcerated and I joined and through
the prison system and when I came out I
met Minister Farrakhan he heard about
the great things I've done in prison and
so he said you're gonna do great work
out here and I did a lot to promote the
Nation of Islam I was a lieutenant in
the nation of song which is I was an FYI
first was the name of the military train
of men the fruit of the fruit of Islam
and that then I became a lieutenant
which I mean I give orders and teach
those who process in a column processing
brothers how to be a good moment a
Nation of Islam and give them
instruction so when I what may believe
the Nation of Islam was deaf then the
leader of the Nation of Islam at that
time mr. Eliezer Muhammad at that time
he called the Honorable Eli's mr. laser
Mohammed who teacher was masterful hired
Muhammad and you have to understand that
this came about in the 30s and there was
ignorant was very prevalent in the
african-american community and it was
also a community of hopelessness there
was no home and so this man came with
some hope and he used a psychology that
said that the black man was God so he
had to use a formula
that worked the make let's look at
ourselves differently because we hated
ourselves and so it worked and he said
the white man was a dominant at that
time Caucasian people was beaten up
lynching us hanging us and everything
else so it was easy for me to conceive
that he was the devil so I thought some
time being a nice restaurant I had a
problem with that picture of massive
fraud Mohammed because he looked white
and when I showed it to some people they
said that's a white man I hid it in my
heart my mind to the members of the
nation in song that I had a problem with
that so when he lies and Hannah died
February 2 25th 1975 I believe I was
devastated I was rushed to Chicago as a
lieutenant I was informed that he had
passed on I was on the plane and
everything and then he told us the next
person would be God himself so you don't
mind I was thinking that God was going
to walk up on a platform and give a talk
this did not happen
it was email warf deen mohammed and
rasli he moved us closer and closer to
the Quran and Sunnah until eventually he
started talking about the teacher of his
father was incorrect and so I took much
to hotter in 1975 on at the hands of
email worker Mohammed my name Neal Ain
Mohammed he is one that gave me that
name their life spanned his grave for
the good things that he did do but then
I found that later I needed to move from
that whole entire experience so in the
late 80s I left even email worth doing
Mohammed community to move on to
continue my studies and endeavors in
Islam now how do you reason was someone
talk to someone from the nation to get
them to understand to come to the real
Islam well when you're talking to you
you have to understand that this person
first you have to see what they're
sincere
we have some people that are in the
Nation of Islam that are very very
sincere an example I'm here in Canada
right now and they had the Caribana fest
so we were downtown we have a the
Canadian dollar Association which I am
the special advisor to
I asked all people to go to our website
Canadian dollar Association website and
see the work we are doing every year we
just had a big conference here as you
know and we had some names that are
known loom we had freeway
Napoleon myself d'Alene Muhammad and
these and dr. Lawrence Brown and we just
had a beautiful conference but the big
thing when you're talking someone from
the Nation of Islam you should know what
you're talking about and you should
understand that this person sincerely
believes this is the truth so you
shouldn't belittle him you shouldn't say
say you're wrong and everything because
everything is not wrong when the devil
wants to make a lie he has to use some
true that's the bait but the hook
actually is the lie so when I approached
them I approached him and shake their
hand and they said summer liquid I will
send one that comes enough this is a
dialog technique some Muslims might
disagree with me and I could answer
they're not Muslim and we're not
supposed to get us wrong but I'm using
Dawa technics in and when I shake their
hand and they fear that I'm sincerely
sincerely caring about them they open up
so what happened this weekend one was
out selling the Nation of Islam paper
whatever it was this weekend downtown
Toronto Horn young and dentists and I
was sitting under the umbrella of the
Islamic Ummah brother table and he
walked up to me and he was looking like
back and forth and I didn't understand I
guess he was looking to see if his
brothers was watching him and he sit
down someone told him that there's a
brother that was in the Nation of Islam
he's older and he's just be the former
bodyguard of Muhammad Ali as well as
Farrakhan and he is knowledgeable of the
nation of storms so he came and asked me
very soft he's excuse me he said why did
you leave the nation using a nation I
said yes he said why did you leave the
nation there was this question I said
well do the death of the leader and I
said after that happened I was looking
and searching for something that would
helped me and I had a problem to picture
a master I told me the host bill and I
said brother I said you're searching our
terrorists
you're searching right now I said when
you find what you need to find I say
embrace it that's an S true Islam I said
I was going to guide you I said but when
he when you see the guard intercepted
and so I didn't have a lot of time to
talk to him because he had to go I said
I gave him my telephone number he took
it he wanted to make contact with me and
I think he had respect so anyone that
came from the Nation of Islam and know
how to give dialog properly we can reach
those people you know and I hope that
Minister Farrakhan you know before he
leaves this life that he clears this and
make it very clear that now you no
longer super long and clear this
argument or clear this controversy up
because people said no he was on the
power of some of them would say this I
said well when I read the back of the
paper when I buy the paper from them
once in a while just to see if they
chain you have you turned to the back of
the paper
he says the Muslim believes these are
not must have believed and one of them
says and we believe in God and Kevin a
personal matter for our bomber
this is as incorrect Shaikh million can
you explain for anonymous an audience or
watching the show and for also the
people from the nation what actually is
the Islamic terror is Lama beliefs you
have what is known as the fire pillows
the faithful is our bear witness there
is no god but Allah Muhammad is His
Messenger
the next is prayer the next is zakat the
next is fasting during the month of
Ramadan and the fifth pillar is Hajj
these are the pillows and they're known
as pillows which means they hold up
something and the chief pillar is la laa
laa 100 ramadasu de la then you have
what is known as the six articles our
belief which is very important is the
belief in the law is the belief in His
angels there's a belief in his books
books we mean the scriptures that was
sent in a final revelation which is
Quran there is debrief in his messengers
and prophets and the final prophet we
know is Muhammad SAW over sell them and
to believe in the day of judgment and
believe and divine decree
which is very important but when we come
to Muhammad the Prophet said overselling
this is where when you're talking to
people they said well I've never heard
of Muhammad well I'm gonna give you a
little joke I've never heard of Obama
right and Obama is the president of the
United States now I've never heard of
him to do his name came up in elections
and he is the 44th president I'm not
sure but he is the Lion of presidents we
do not follow the laws of George
Washington today because whether those
laws are outdated they wouldn't apply to
what to society and growth and
development that has reached them so
Obama is in the Lincoln line of the
president's that came before him and he
read it now we follow the laws and acted
by Congress through President Obama
so we're prophethood the prophets
started out with Adam being the first
prophet of God and moving all through
the great fathers Moses David and Esau
Ali Salim and till we reached Mohammed
so Mohammed got the final message that
God has given to man to the day of
judgment a comments are very clear that
he is a lot more mercy to all mankind
Esau Ali Salim got the message to a
certain group of people and he made it
very clear some the Christians
regretting upon that this message was to
this group of people but the message of
the Quran is to every human being and
that's why in Islam you'll find people
from all different ethnic group and
races now we just have two minutes left
can you tell us sheikh and lane as you
had once so eloquently said how can we
avoid getting pimped by the Shaitaan yes
yeah we have to be very careful this
I'll call him I did a lecturer at so as
you know at the conference called
Shaitaan the pill and he's pimping the
whole wall and if you don't want to get
poked by him then you have to stay away
from the entertainment halls of the pill
what are the entertainment hollered up
in the movie theater
you have to stay away from script clubs
as massage Paulo's and people that talk
filthy languages and if I'll miss them
he should still around the Muslims who
are seeking to be upright stay more you
keep you a hired mind attached to the
Quran that oh he make sure that you have
taqwa and remember you should have your
your your amen
your faith and believe there should be
as though you're walking through a
garden that has a lot of thorns and that
your Amman is very far too like cotton
and if you go through and not careful
that cotton is going to get ripped if
you're not careful in this environment
young fellows young sister whether male
or female while they are young then
you're going to start to lose your Eman
and in conclusion there's just like this
there for horses coming down a dusty
road and you're standing on the side of
the road the horse might not run you
over but you won't get something to dust
from that horse so if you live in this
environment
you only get some of the best of hoof on
you so you have to be very careful and
Omar Abdullah and said he said the
Muslim that mixes with the people and
endured their harm is better than a
Muslim who does not mix with the people
and does not enter their home
thank you very much Schaffer being with
us thank you
and I like just given I'll say that I'm
in Minnesota
I'm with domestic mess Odawa Tsukasa and
Jeremy we need your support
saving the message there so please go to
our website in in.net and support
bastard Dawa Salam aleikum Jessica Lowe
Haider made the creator of the heavens
and earth Allah reward you thank you
and that was the former bodyguard of the
world champion heavyweight champion
famous Muhammad Ali who is a Muslim who
is one who's made a conscious decision
to acquire peace by submitting himself
submitting his will to the will of the
creator of the heavens and earth to be
obedient to be in line with what
everything the Creator wants him to do
that is what a Muslim is so there are
many many thousands of thousands of
people who are coming to this beautiful
way of life the way of life that was
lived by Jesus Christ peace be upon him
Moses peace be upon Abraham peace be
upon him Noah these were just a few of
the messengers that came with this way
of life they taught people the same
religion the same way do what God wants
you to do do it on his terms
acquire peace by submitting to the will
of God by submitting to what the crater
wants you to do and the last and final
messenger sent to mankind the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him came with the
same way as a mercy he was sent as a
mercy to the world so get to know a
little bit more about us about this
wonderful way of life continue to come
back here on the Deen show and if you
want to accept the way of all the
messengers you can do it right now you
can call the number on the screen 1 800
662 lat
and until next time until we meet again
continue to tune in make dua for us and
we'll see you inshallah God willing
until then peace be unto you
come see what everyone's talking about
who if you find one contradiction it
can't be from God but the rational idea
the rational explanation is you do your
best to give up for spring goddess why I
will never give up spreading this
message okay you take that necessary
step you don't know if you're gonna live
to tomorrow so you gotta find that urges
you to do the right thing right now the
reality of life usually doesn't sink in
until tragedy comes you get a few bad
people the media grabs a hold of that
and spends it the way they want to if
you say that you're not believe in Jesus
you have stepped outside of this man you
cannot be a Muslim is that ended our
faith too
you